of you i love you all
happy tuesday everyone
oh i missed you so
dana preno will never host again
too many of the comments were positive
but we've got so many things going on
which means it's time for
greggs i see a trend that's worthy of a
fantastic monologue
[Music]
wait wait that's not what i ordered
you left something out
oh sorry greg uh yes uh you don't get
this brilliance on special report in
your face bret bear
gut-felled rules
yeah
that's more like it vocal guy
so there are big changes afoot and it's
not just ainsley earhart quitting
smokeless tobacco
she's not watching
boils down to one word limits we've
reached them yep we put our foot down
like a drunk paul pelosi running a red
light
let's start at the beginning the recall
of the sf school board members after
years of wokeness voters finally put
their sorry asses to sleep remember they
wanted to change the names of schools
during a coveted crisis the voters told
them to hit the road and in san fran
that road is covered with
there's netflix telling its employees if
you're too sensitive to work here don't
god if i had a nickel for every time i
said that when i was directing those
snuff films in the 80s
oh yeah
same thing with spotify who backed joe
rogan over neil young and other washed
up artists their cries for boycotts when
ignored like my assistant's request for
bathroom breaks
not on my watch
so how about the media well cnn top
brass turns over as the new boss
announces that partisanship is done
but nobody heard the announcement
because his head was so far up biden's
ass
so like kat's college degree we'll
believe it when we see it
but at least cnn admits their trump
derangement poisoned their brand
ah i bet brian stelter is sweating right
now
and it has nothing to do with taking the
stairs
because he's overweight
the washington post fires awoke reporter
who bad-mouthed co-workers on twitter
and after some wimpiness the boss they
finally found their limit and off she
went like jim acosta's hairpiece after
an eric swawwell fart
bill maher now shows up every friday
sounding like the bastard son of henry
kissinger and margaret thatcher
after years of progressivism it feels
like marr found his limit even through
that cumulus cloud of pot smoke
sf left the d.a chaser boudin got it
recalled like a toyota with defective
airbags after the public had enough of
violent crime
this may be a sign of more recalls aimed
against pro-crime soros spawned
workstars
johnny depp wins a televised trial the
public largely agreeing with his side of
the story the me too defense didn't
protect amber heard from facts
people saw through her crap
[Laughter]
turns out she loves corn on the cob
picnic season
now elon musk announces he's voting
republican for the first time in his
life so what do all these things have in
common well people found their limits
the slippery slopes finally hit a brick
wall but let's not rejoice just yet
there are other places also screaming
for that brick wall
black on black crime at one point does
the murder rate seem unacceptable to
democrats we're already there but not
the dems why is that what's their limit
artificial intelligence are we paying
attention to it to even know if there is
a limit because limits to technology are
elusive we never think about them until
it's too late we're all enslaved by sexy
robots
that's my dream
children as gender experiments if you
told me the solution for gender
confusion in a preteen is surgery and
hormones i'd say who died and made you
joseph mengele
the only transitioning this
administration should be concentrating
on is the one that's going to happen in
2024 when they hand the white house keys
back to the adults
yeah huh
excuse me
i'll take it why not
by the way sex ed in high school i get
it fine but gender instruction for
toddlers knock it off you pervert
and yes drag shows are entertaining it's
awesome seeing performers who are bad at
singing comedy and stripping all at the
same time
but for kids really nah
and what are those teachers unions
haven't they had enough of this haven't
we had enough of them they destroy our
schools then come out against school
choice so you're stuck with them is it
time to say my kid my choice it's
happening with the school boards but
behind every school board is a school
union
trans athletes there aren't that many so
what's the problem well when
biologically female athletes are no
longer winning
where's that limit going to come up
trans activists don't care when should
you care illegal immigration when do we
ask what's the right number of people to
let in determine that then protect the
southern border but we don't know our
limits because no one wants to ask the
number split the issue into process and
illegality and you solve the problem
january 6th this rehash never ends and
for one purpose only politics do we have
a limit to this media party conclusion
it's basically liz cheney's audition for
the view
at least there she'll be known as the
hot one
[Applause]
[Music]
and here's a tip when casting propaganda
don't make adam schiff a leading man
that's like casting flipper to play
lassie
and we're seeing people everywhere
pushing back against those who push our
limits
[Music]
yes that's when i found out i'm not
adopted oh excuse me can we get some
water please sure you want sparkling tap
or meatless uh tap's fine
yeah so i love this place uh michelin
star chef uh the menu is incredible i
think you're gonna oh my gosh excuse me
excu that's enough that's enough who
cares it's free no limits man
never classy she is so sassy feeling my
line slowly losing her mind can't keep
opinions to herself with white fragility
on her bookshelf
over-educated and under-medicated she
won't be happy till we're all castrated
she's the one that we call dirtbag
i'm so sorry about that folks deb you
can't keep doing this over serving the
customers plus you filed 82 hr
complaints since tuesday sorry i care
about creating an inclusive non-toxic
work environment you don't even work
here don't mansplain my employment
status to me well i've never once
interviewed you for a job oh that
reminds me i'd like to file a complaint
about you denying me an interview this
is uh
[Applause]
the point is society progresses under
the assumption that it's actual progress
but like criminal justice reform it's
not the case when ideology replaces
reality instead society breaks down too
when people suffer you know just today i
had to let go of my butler
it's very very sad
but we are waking up and retaking
control because if we've learned
anything in the past couple years it's
when it comes to limits nothing should
be off limits including term limits
let's welcome
tonight's guests
he's never serious even on serious
comedian co-host of the jim norton sam
roberts show on siriusxm jim norton
yes
yes
way to thank the audience jim a lot of
people don't do that she got more time
on the sideline than a jug of gatorade
former sportscaster michelle tafoya
he's not your father's republican leader
he just looks like he is
american conservative union chairman max
she's got more fake hair than her
british judge yeah foxy's contributor
jim always a pleasure to see you thank
you greg it's great to see you it's
great to hear you know you are a
political shaman yes people go to you
wherever the deepest questions when
there's a political turmoil are you
sensing like me that there's a movement
towards limits and do limits help you in
your life that's an excellent question
it's a two-part question it is yes and i
forgot the first part already the first
part is do you see a trend coming in
this idea of limitations and do you find
limits helpful in your life um limits
are not helpful in my life but women
don't want to sleep with me so there are
limits
and as far as limits are they going to
change anything is there a trend coming
no i think we're deluding ourselves
hoping every time something happens like
now it's about to change it's not going
to change it's not going to change well
that's very negative sorry guys my
apologies let's go back it's going to
change yeah i think i was going to say
we can edit that out it is going to
change right it's going to be great no
no no
it's never going to change it's going to
get worse and worse and worse and then
we're all going to die
[Laughter]
it sounds like my inner monologue
that's exactly what i say every morning
when i wake up
it's painful michelle you live in middle
america which a lot of people you know
it's weird because that's in america
unlike the middle east
right
how fed up are they
tell us well you know what it's
interesting because i drove to my son's
baseball game yesterday and it was way
out in the countryside and i felt like
you know well i ain't that america i
felt like john mellencamp was singing in
my head but then i turn around i go back
to the twin cities and it's very very
liberal in the in minneapolis-st paul
um i can't decide what i'm more
disturbed by right now the fact that
you've just said it's not it's only
going to get worse or the fact that i
never want to eat corn on the cob ever
[Laughter]
it's uh both are depressing i was
hopeful greg until i was invited onto a
podcast recently and i was invited with
this we want to talk about your great
career and your new podcast we think
is it okay if we talk to you for about
30 or 40 minutes it was someone i knew
from my past so i said okay yeah the
second i got on
bam was ambushed with you're anti-crt
you're a racist you're uh you cannot
read the florida law without it being a
homophobe i mean i was absolutely
ambushed and just when i was thinking
that all these signs from netflix and
cnn things were turning in that
direction that you alluded to
boy did i get a wake-up call there is
like there are these things that pop out
again and again and i and i mean even on
this network sometimes it happens but we
won't get into that will we cat
i guess not no
matt uh
are you noticing a kind of a wave i
think it started with young king don't
you kind of like totally you know it's
like a revolt in the commonwealth of
virginia it was parents you know they
were called domestic terrorists for
saying why is my five-year-old reading
about these sex acts with like you know
cartoon books it was kind of insane and
uh but i also think we have to separate
what's going on society from politics so
is it going to change politically hell
yes we're going to kick their butts it's
going to be an amazing red wave not so
much because the republican party is so
perfect but these guys have bungled
everything you can imagine the real
question michelle's talking about is
even if the voters revolt can you
actually change all the insanity that's
rolling through these institutions and
through the schools and i'm you know i'm
more dubious until we have a lot of
political success well i guess okay so
this is what good then it goes back to
what jimmy's saying which is like that
it's you're kind of saying that
culturally it always it's entropy it
just always kind of goes towards bad
well it's not about what we're arguing
about we love to argue and we love to be
right it's not about the issue the issue
is the excuse to attack each other and
we're always going to love attacking
each other so no matter what the issues
are we are still the same we can blame
trump we can blame biden doesn't matter
we're the same it's not going to change
interesting sorry i just wanted to bore
everybody no
i think you hit a major point there cat
care to respond to jimmy's assertion
that it's about human nature that we
can't change
yeah i think that's true i think
everybody's
and
what
i'm sorry but all of us are
and the difference with this i think is
it's way easier for some people to you
know kind of gain power control they
don't have to really be good at anything
they don't have to develop a skill they
don't have to work really hard they have
to get upset and have their feelings be
hurt and say you know you offended me
for this reason that's on this list of
reasons we consider you know things that
are acceptable to consider offensive and
then you're the most powerful person in
the room without actually having to do
anything so that's going to be pretty
difficult for people to give up
especially when it does actually
actually does work so often where people
are actually afraid to say that they've
had enough of it it's good that you have
these examples where it is but there are
consequences for saying that you've had
enough of something too because then
you're canceled that's is that's another
great point thank you yes yes i'm very
positive because dana was guest hosting
yesterday and everybody liked how
positive she was
but you know what
i'm gonna i'm gonna rebut you and i'm
gonna say that generally most americans
are nice polite people right
but
i think they're running out of patience
it's like you can only mess with people
for so long and then they go okay this
is now and i think that's what how
progress works it's a little bit of
chaos and then it comes back and then it
gets chaotic that's my positive spin on
this well greg that really hurts i guess
i really took you apart just there yeah
yeah the way to humiliate me in front of
the audience
but you know why i think it's that way
because when you look at every like the
pundit shows where everybody argues on
every network has them when's the last
time on any of those you heard someone
go ah you're right
yeah never only here ever we do it here
yeah i admit that i'm wrong almost every
night yeah although it won't happen
tonight
[Laughter]
because then uh
i'm not gonna do it
all right before we go here's some news
i got new book tour dates this is
exciting i'll be at foxwoods casino in
connecticut in october that sounds
exciting and smart financial center in
the houston area in november why can't
we just say houston it's pretty big i
don't understand that but get tickets at
cheatgutfelt.com and find out why and up
next at nfl coach opines it ends up with
a massive fine
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else